اهلا سهام اهلا نادين نعم نحن نقف الان
امام سوق الليل في ينبع التاريخيه من اقدم
الاسواق على سواحل البحر الاحمر صدى زميل
المصور نصر ياخذ لكم جوله سريعه لان اعرف
انه وقتي معكم قصير جدا طبعا هذا السوق
سوق الليله التراثي ومن اعرق واقدم
الاسواق في ينبع وفي سواحل البحر الاحمر
جميعا طبعا هذا السوق كان وجهه رئيسيه
للتجار على سواحل البحر الاحمر القادمين
من افريقيا وايضا من الخليج العربي طبعا
قبل انطلاقات انطلاقهم الى رحلاتهم
البحريه ياتون الى ذات السوق لتزود
بالبضائع والمنتجات الموجوده على ساحر
البحر الاحمر طبعا ينبع الان تشهد قدوم
كروز لشركه ايطاليه ام اس سي هذا الكروز
ضخها بالكثير من الجنسيات المتنوعه من
السياح كما نشاهد الان امامنا على الشاشه
خاصه من ايطاليا ومن اسبانيا وايضا من
سويسرا هؤلاء السي يستمتعون بالاجواء كما
نشاهد وبالاسواق الشعبيه والبضائع
المتنوعه هنا في
ينبع التاريخيه طبعا هذا السوق تم ترميمه
بالكامل من قبل هيئه التراث التابعه
لوزاره الثقافه السعوديه على عدد من
المراحل ايضا لا يزال الترميم جاري في بعض
البيوت القديمه نشاهد الان امامنا هذه
الساحه الرائعه والجميله امام ميناء ينبع
التاريخي ونشاهد ايضا المطاعم والمقاهي
والجلسات المتنوعه طبعا ينبع تشتهر ايضا
بمهنه صيد الاسماك وتنوع الاسماك الموجوده
هنا فمن اراد ان يتناول وجبه سمك لذيذه
وشهيه على الافطار طبعا ياتي الى هذا
المكان الاذان المغرب تقريبا كان قبل يعني
ساعه بالضبط فتسال الاجواء هادئه بعض
الشيء والناس اغلبها في بيوتها لكن رغم
ذلك نشاهد بعض الناس والعوائل والاطفال
قرروا ان يتناول وجبه الافطار ويستمتعوا
بالاجواء اكثر من رائع هنا في ينبع
التاريخيه طبعا نشاهد ايضا هناك بعض
المقاهي والجلسات الخفيفه والجميله
البليله الينبعاويه الذره ايضا القهوه
الخاصه بهم التمر الجلسات الجميله
والاستمتاع بالاجواء الرائعه من العائلات
والاطفال وجميع الفئات العمريه ينبع
التاريخيه مكان رائع للزياره ولعل اختيار
الكروز العالمي الوقوف هنا في ينبع يعطي
دلاله قاطعه على اهميه
المدينه التاريخيه طبعا على مبال ما نخلص
معاكم طبعا حتشوفوا البليله ايضا هذه
البليله مشهوره الى دين السهام هنا في
ينبع بالطريقه الخاصه بالخل طبعا اعطيني
تحابيش اللي عليها يا معلم حطوا عليها
مخلل
بنجر او شمندر كما يحب الناس يسموه الجزر
المخلل الجميل وايضا الملح طبعا رائعه جدا
ولذيذه جدا ومن اجمل الاكلات الشعبيه في
ينبع وان احرص دائما كلمه اجي ينبع اني
اذوق شكرا يا معلم شكرا جزيلا رائعه جدا
يا نبيل ومن اجمل اللايفات السياحيه من
على مشارف البحر الاحمر وهذه المدينه ينبع
التاريخيه شكرا جزيلا استمتع يا عبد
الرحمن وسنعود اكيد اليك في سياق مسائل
عربيه في الايام المقبله